[Music]
foreign
devil may cry 5 and well the whole devil
may cry franchise is one of the best
games i've never played
until now devil may cry has gone under
my radar for quite a while
i honestly didn't even know we were on
the fifth entry i was aware of the
game's existence but never had that much
drive to actually play it it seemed like
a game i wasn't really going to enjoy
which is why i never bought it the
game's combat reminds me of bayonetta
and seeing as i barely
got an hour into that game that further
proved to me that this isn't something i
should buy
although i thought it would be fun to
not only step out of my comfort zone in
terms of gaming genres but also showcase
my emotions going through this
as i'm new to the series but because i'm
new however that means i literally know
nothing about the story or its universe
and for my small knowledge of the game i
know that this is dante although i've
seen lots of promotional material of
this guy who also looks like dante from
the past games because of his shorter
haircuts so i'm honestly not sure if i'm
right or not
seeing as i have very little knowledge
of the game i obviously have numerous
questions like why does dante have
powers how did he get these powers what
are the creatures that we fight in game
and where do they come from
so in hopes of answering all those
questions i'm going to be spending the
next couple days beating the game and
i'll return once i'm done
[Music]
this was fantastic devil may cry was a
blast to play
the style system that has become a
staple of the franchise was easily the
driving factor for this from a gameplay
perspective the ranks go from d
to triple s and trying to achieve that
triple s or even an s in general was
invigorating know that if i pay
attention enough and utilize my skills
i could pull it off dmc however was
close to becoming one of those games
where i start to give up
quickly to provide more context some
games have challenges or they're called
challenge runs allowing you to earn one
to three stars depending on your
performance
usually i feel good getting 3 stars back
to back but eventually i start to slip
i then start to go on a streak of 1 or 2
stars since the challenges are getting
tougher which i'm totally ok with i want
the levels to challenge me but i don't
have that same drive to constantly
replay the same level just to get that
extra star i missed
a good example is from my recent video
on the shooter bullet storm to get every
challenge accessible to the player the
player must acquire 41 stars while
there's 3 pages worth of levels and
10 levels per page so you only have to
do about a third of the levels at a 3
star rating to get all the levels
so if you get a 1 or 2 star during one
of the missions
why even try getting better when you
don't need to there's a dozen more
levels you can do mediocre at and still
unlock everything
but for some reason i never felt like
this with devil may cry and i couldn't
figure out for the life of me
why but then i finally realized it's
because you can physically see your
performance
the game's ratings are a reflection of
your skill a triple s in dmc requires
the player to flawlessly kill every
enemy without skipping a beat or being
hit
it's the highest peak of gameplay this
in other video games like call of duty
would be clearing a level or group of
enemies without being hit or maybe being
100 accurate
yes the feeling of pulling a feed off
like this is great but it feels much
better in dmc because the game is
physically showing you in real time
how well you're performing even though
someone who triple s is every fight
versus someone spamming the same moves
and getting a d
rating can still complete the game it
feels much better when you finally hit
that
s for the first time the letters are
also called stylish ranks for a reason
you look really good and stylish when
you're at the s rank constantly dodging
and outputting damage at the same time
like it's some sort of dance and dmc
made me want to achieve an s at any
moment and it all started at mission 4.
v is easily my favorite character in
this game from his looks to his
mannerisms to his actual combat
i loved him his movements and combos
felt smooth in my hands almost
immediately he was the first character
that i achieved not only an
s with but multiple triple s's with v
felt very
new player friendly and i think that's
why i disliked some of nero's fights and
a majority of my playtime with dante
v controls the combat with three
familiars shadow griffin and nightmare
they do all the fighting but due to them
being familiar
they can't finish off the other demons
merely wound them critically so v
has to step in to deliver the final blow
this was a great gameplay
loop using the familiars to defeat the
demons then finishing them off with v
i never got near the fights cause i
never needed to i would come in for the
finishing blow then use griffin to fly
away to safety it was just overall
smooth clean combat
because of how easy he felt to me
anytime i was given the option
v was always my go-to pick nero and not
dante as i had originally thought in the
intro was actually quite fun
the devil breakers got some meeting used
to but i understood the basics i did
however start to become overwhelmed when
almost after every mission i was getting
two new devil breakers and now i had to
remember what all of them did
it was easier before the mission since i
got to choose my loadout but on the fly
in combat it was a little tougher
other than that nero was pretty fun i
got used to his sword play and the whip
was easily the strongest tool he had
allowing me to keep the combos going
from wherever i was in the arena
dante however really bothered me and i
don't think it's the dev's fault for
this decision i think it's more due to
me not being familiar with dmc
and its gameplay loop in regards to
dante i should have mentioned this
earlier but before
and during the missions you can upgrade
your equipment with red orbs you gain
during these missions you can either
upgrade your health or
devil gauge but it will most likely be
going towards upgrading your moves
either by getting new ones or making the
current ones better it was all very
self-explanatory and the game also
provides you a training arena called the
void allowing you to get better with
these moves so you can perform at your
absolute best but even with this i still
couldn't really enjoy dante's fights to
quickly sum up our previous protagonists
we have v
with three different options of
attacking being his familiars and all
the various moves we can purchase with
them
nero while having multiple devil
breakers to remember each one had the
same general idea
while they all did something different
at the end of the day they were all
devil breakers besides that he has his
sword and his gun
so also three methods of attacking and
once again that's taking into account
the moves and combos you could buy for
his sword
dante to me had too much going on dante
also doesn't become playable until
mission 10 so this all occurs within 9
or 10 missions depending on your choice
in mission 13.
dante by the end of the game has 4 close
range weapons 4
long range weapons 4 styles each with
their own style action
and 2 other forms devil trigger and sin
devil trigger
the difference between nero and v versus
dante's moves and equipment
is astronomical and it was just too much
of a large jump for me to handle
i ended up changing loadouts to fit what
i was comfortable with which was the
devil sword sparta and the motorbike for
close range the pistols for long range
and only swapping between trickster and
swordmaster styles
also remember that each of the close
range weapons also have moves and combos
you can buy so it's not just four basic
weapons it's four weapons with unique
and different moves that you need to
remember
i'm not entirely sure if the point was
to give you a large amount of weapons
that allow the player to pick and choose
what they want and don't want but seeing
as the loadouts each have four slots it
felt intended for the player to carry
every weapon they received and use all
of them but i just couldn't do that
at least for me this was quite a lot to
remember and do keep in mind that you
are constantly switching protagonists
throughout the game from v
to nero to dante so you have to remember
all of their moves and hopefully not
forget the other character's moves and
weapons or you're going to be stuck
doing the same move throughout the
entire mission the game does give you an
option somewhere to make the controller
simpler but i felt that that took away
from the whole point of devil may cry
and felt like an easy way out to me now
i was giving the weapons a chance at
least if i felt the groove with them
that i would keep them but if not i
removed them from my loadout entirely
which is a good transition to the ranged
weapon since i used
nothing but the pistols the hat i liked
not only because it looked fantastic but
the idea made sense to me it's a risk
reward weapon that makes you spend red
orbs but rewards you for doing so
it definitely requires a bit more skill
to wield than your typical player but i
liked the idea of it the shotgun and the
rocket launcher i could not get behind
as i genuinely didn't see a purpose to
having them all in my loadout the ranged
weapons don't do that much damage anyway
and even with the addition of the
gunslinger
style i didn't feel like any damage i
was doing was significant
i'm gonna have to play around with these
a bit more because i feel like i'm
missing out on the potential of these
ranged weapons but regardless of whether
i am or not
it wasn't clear during my playthrough so
i just stuck to the pistols
this is why i said v was very noob
friendly he was simple
basic and not overwhelming to play at
all he never got new weapons or gear
just new moves for his summons and
that's it
now to be fair when i did get into a
groove with dante things worked out
incredibly well
but they weren't as common as with v or
nero once again i don't think it's a
fault on the game for capcom but me not
being familiar with all of this as if i
played the previous games i would assume
this would be a lot easier to handle but
still as someone new to the series this
was quite the overwhelming problem for
me on top of the protagonists getting
stronger the enemies also change
throughout the missions starting out
with typical fodder that go down in a
few hits to ones that can teleport or
have shields that you need to break
through i don't have any issues with
this at all it made the combat fun just
like any other stylistic fighting
game of its kind as it's a mind game of
remembering your moves watching the
enemies and planning a proper setup
whenever new enemies get thrown into the
mix it changes up the combat and makes
it feel fresh and this is something that
i want to convey that even when i was
struggling with dante and getting
overwhelmed
at his arsenal i was still having fun it
definitely would have been more
enjoyable had i known all the combos and
moves but i was still having fun
regardless and i think that's the most
important part that no matter how little
or
larger knowledge of these movesets are
you can still have fun fighting
the other enemies you fight besides the
common fodder are the bosses i don't
remember the exact number but they're
around
16 or so bosses in the game most of them
were excellent fights
out of these however i was disappointed
with four of them that being one of
yurizin's fights the clyfothroots
gilgamesh
and virgil the last one desperately
needs him explaining and i promise it's
not a hay piece on virgil just allow me
some time to explain why the clyfoth
roots i won't give too much hate towards
only because they were the first boss in
the game it was to help ease the player
into the gameplay loop
the moves were semi-predictable and the
damage dealt was negligible
so it wasn't a great boss compared to
the others coming later in the game but
it didn't need to be
because the story jumps back and forth
you do get to fight yeresen multiple
times we fight him as nero in the
beginning then
again is nearer later then flashback to
when we see dante lose to him back at
the intro
the first two surprised me but repeated
the same formula of you having to lose
in order to continue the first time
fooled me since i wasn't expecting that
and the second one as well since i'd
assumed we would get some sort of
revenge on him since he beat us last
time
dante's version was flat out dumb to me
i understand it needed to be in the game
because of the story as we're now seeing
things from his perspective as opposed
to neros but i realized immediately i
had to lose the fight to continue so i
didn't even bother fighting and just let
him kill me so i wouldn't even really
call this a boss fight dmc like many
other games have a super tough boss in
the intro you're supposed to lose to but
if you do manage to kill him you do get
a secret ending which just ends the game
as you're supposed to kill yourself
later
but you did it now sadly however you
cannot progress the story unless you
lose so there was really no point in
trying during dante's encounter so to
explain what i mentioned
earlier my issue with virgil was that it
was my least comfortable character dante
versus the toughest boss in the game it
was the worst handicap
imaginable and it was because of that
little knowledge that i got slapped hard
it was the one and only time i had to
use a gold orb
what i mean by this is when i played
with v i understood his moves and combos
because of this i knew what i could get
away with during the gurion knight boss
fight while i did stay back for most of
the fight even when i was within
touching range of him i was still
continuing to pressure him since i knew
what i could get away with with dante
however because the lack of knowledge i
had in regards to his moveset there
wasn't much i could work with which
meant i wasn't doing moves or combos out
of confidence but rather desperation
all of that culminated in a very
frustrating boss fight but even with the
multiple handicaps virgil's fight was
excellent i've never felt more invested
in a fight more than this one
some of it due to the story elements
that led to this but also because
he was a hard boss i like when games are
hard so when i'm in a fight that's an
uphill battle from the start i become
drastically more interested in it and
virgil sparked that feeling for me i had
to actually pay attention to his moves
speeds and their distances an example of
the opposite of this would be the
gilgamesh boss fight gilgamesh was a
stupid simple fight
destroy his legs then use the whip to
launch to his back and hit him until he
dies
i never worried about getting hit or
dying and even if i was hit it wasn't a
major setback since it did
very little damage anyway i didn't need
to learn his move since it rarely
affected my health or combos
virgil was the opposite i had to
remember what every move was i had to
time his dashes correctly or i'd be hit
i had to run instead of dodge his sword
swings because the area of effect was so
large i could still be caught in it i
also had to learn an entirely new
moveset when he went into devil trigger
mode there's no argument that virgil was
the best boss fight in the game the
reason i called the disappointing
earlier was because after the fight i
was more mad at myself
this could have been an excellent fight
one where those scales really did tip in
both sides but due to me getting
comfortable with only a couple moves and
not understanding other combos
i felt like i won not because i was
better but because i got lucky watching
back the footage made me realize that
the devil trigger mode helped me more
than i thought it did
most of my damage was from this mode i
do understand the point of devil trigger
was to do
tons of damage but you can even tell
from the gameplay without it i probably
wouldn't have won
i couldn't produce damage with the
combos i knew so i relied heavily on the
devil triggered to win the fight
it was easily the best boss fight in the
game and i have to applaud capcom for
making it worth the time to get here but
i felt i sold a lot of the tension for
myself because of my lack of skill
in the intro of the video i felt like i
wasn't going to like dmc because i
played bayonetta before and didn't enjoy
its gameplay so how could i like this
game's combat
i'm happy to say however that i was
completely wrong even though the scoring
is completely optional and does not
affect anything from the story
i constantly strive to hit that triple s
and when i ruined my rating because i
got hit
i was angry at myself seeing that double
s on screen during an
intense fight only to realize i was hit
by a super slow attack that brought me
down to a b
was absolutely demoralizing this
completely optional mechanic made me
want to achieve the highest rating i
could even if getting something lower
would have changed nothing in the game
and it's because that letter
translates to the flow of combat like i
said in the beginning getting a triple s
is like killing everyone in the room
without being touched
other games can do this too but it
doesn't feel as great as opposed to when
you can physically see your performance
get better or worse in real time
and i think that was the best part of
dmc
i get it
who brought the marshmallows because i'm
bringing the fire
so i knew the story was going to be
interesting
one because of the mysterious plot that
the fifth game has but also because i
haven't played the previous four games
thankfully the history of dmc was quite
helpful in getting the basics down
a few of my questions like who dante but
not actually dante is as well as how his
powers came to be were answered so it
was an excellent summarization from what
i gathered dante and virgil are the kids
of the demon named sparta
dante and virgil like many brothers have
multiple rivalries with each other some
of which seem to have occurred within
the past games
dante now owns a business aptly named
devil may cry which is used as a front
so he can further hunt any demons that's
brought into the human world
the intro of the game quickly gets us
acquainted with our other cast members
by showing the names of the characters
who appear like nero and v
lady and trish also return from the past
games but they don't get shown until a
little later so demons have returned
once again
and this giant plant thing called the
clyfoth has blossomed in the street
v and nero have a conversation with each
other in which we learn that nero's arm
was taken by the demon in front of them
v also is labeled as the mysterious one
very different to nero or dante who are
called devil hunters so v
is becoming quite the well mysterious
character
the gang loses against the demon
eurozone so v in nero retreat
dante also calls nero dead weight which
clearly irks him as it will continue to
be brought up even towards the end of
the game we then get introduced to our
final cast member nico now i do want to
point out that i did an extensive amount
of research on the devil may cry
wikipedia after i beat the game so i
could understand what exactly was going
on because as we'll soon discover not
all of it was quite obvious to me this
is also probably a good time to mention
this too that if you come across this
video and you are knowledgeable in the
story in any way
let me know how this story felt for you
as i wonder if you and i had different
emotions and experiences due to our
different levels of knowledge on the
game's story
the first thing i have to point out is
the cinematography of this game
it clearly has a bias towards cinematic
action shots and slow motion destruction
and i'm all for it the cutscenes were
wonderfully crafted and as someone who's
a fan of the recent resident evil games
it's great to see the re engine put to
good use for other games as well because
i genuinely can't get over how the
recent capcom games have looked and dmc
is no exception
i can't imagine what the fanbase was
thinking at the time when the first
trailer dropped as the look between dmc
4 and 5 is practically night and day
so far at this moment the story had me
hooked because a lot of things were left
unanswered who was the mysterious person
why did he take nero's arm also what was
nero's arm
fans of the series already knew that
nero's arm was the devil bringer which
housed the amato
or virgil's a weapon i knew absolutely
none of this and i hope many fans didn't
figure it out right away as i feel the
yamato could have been a dead giveaway
to some
but of course this is from the
perspective of someone who's unfamiliar
with the lore the story also did a
really good job at differentiating the
characters they didn't feel bland or
overlap in any way and that was a breath
of fresh air i also got to understand
their motives for their actions almost
immediately nero is sick of being under
dante's shadow so he tries to show off
and prove the two aren't the same
nico's fan-like reaction to dante makes
sense as her mother made dante's iconic
pistol so she's clearly a fan of him
speaking of which dante is cocky and
comedic always making light of bad
situations and sometimes being a real
nuisance but
if i was the son of sparta who had taken
down demons seemingly tougher than the
ones that's in front of me
of course i'm gonna be cocky the only
characters i really couldn't jive with
were trish and lady but i think that was
more of capcom's decision to put them on
the back burner in this game as i know
that they were a part of the pass games
but i'm unsure if they got more screen
time in this game as compared to the
ones before
at some point the duo split off and went
their separate ways here is where i
discovered the co-op feature of dmc and
a large amount of small details put into
the game by the developers
during some of the early missions with
nero i saw this icon that said starring
dmc crew on screen i figured that it was
maybe a soundtrack kicking in or
something until later i realized it was
actually showing another player play
this section i just did
it was a neat little aspect of not only
showing off the different perspectives
throughout the game but also the ability
to have other players show off to each
other capcom could have simply played a
scripted event which would occur if it
does say dmc crew but they went the
extra mile to have the possibility of
having other players join you and for
the later missions specifically mission
13
it was the best experience i had with
the game mission 13
named three warriors lets you pick
between the three protagonists already
this gives you a good amount of replay
value since you can experience three
different versions of this mission
because the three choices but even
better your paths can cross with one of
the other hunters allowing for a true
co-op experience
i played with adante who clearly knew
what he was doing and we were able to
maintain an s
and double s ranks for quite a bit of
time it was a blast and really started
this high point for me where just
everything that occurred from the story
to gameplay was intense and captivating
and that went all the way from mission
13 to the end of the credits that's not
to say everything before mission 13 was
bad this just hit a new high point for
me the other bit i mentioned earlier was
the small details
small details to me never have negatives
they don't diminish the gameplay if they
aren't included but they will always
positively affect the gameplay if they
are
four of which stood out to me like v's
hair moving when griffin flaps his wings
near him or
nero's devil breaker matching the one
equipped before the cutscene
and me so low
this one next to it come on nico
this one sure the other two were related
to nico
i noticed after a couple phone calls in
game that every call was different from
its beginning cinematic of nero or v
calling to when she actually arrives on
scene it was wonderful
i also noticed that at least before the
gurion boss fight i called her to spend
some orbs and her van was still seen in
the background during a cutscene
i checked other gameplay to see if i was
right and i was correct if you do not
visit nico her van does
not show up in the back of the cutscene
it was a very welcoming and subtle touch
to the game
continuing back to the story the game
really dragged on the mystery of e for
quite a while
i liked that however every time
something was added to the story via
flashback or dialogue i was getting more
questions than answers which meant the
final payoff of understanding who he
really is
was definitely worth the wait a cutscene
shows later that it was v
who took nero's arm i was already
shocked until i realized i was wrong and
that it was actually
virgil this is where the story started
to confuse me though from what i
gathered virgil used the yamato to split
his body in half so to speak so instead
of being half devil half human
in one body it was two separate entities
one full human being v
and one full devil being in from the
cutscene it seemed like v
didn't like what he saw on the devil
side so he hired dante to defeat him my
confusion starts
here i think that v realized that
yurizin was too powerful to defeat due
to his past hatred in the previous games
and of course that manifested into
urazin so he wanted dante to kill
yurizin but it seemed like v
had other ulterior motives as v combined
with eurozone to turn back into virgil
so did he split himself then combine
himself again as to not become the
fragile hooded figure we see in the
beginning but rather a
full strength devil hunter that's what
it seemed like
the only thing that i truly do not
understand is the difference of
urazin and v they're essentially the two
halves that make
virgil so how does the mind of these two
work are they two completely separate
entities and virgil's mind was in we'll
call limbo until he combined again or
was there something else going on
genuinely if you do know the answer or
have an idea let me know because this
was probably the biggest question i had
about the game's story and it was quite
mind-boggling
to understand once virgil is reborn we
take control of dante and attempt to
defeat him before this we have to fight
nightmare
griffin and shadow all at the same time
which i thought was really cool they
were quite troublesome to deal with but
i genuinely liked it eventually though
we do come face to face with virgil and
honestly i liked the symbolism that they
showcased between the two brothers
dante's dressed in red virgil's dressed
in blue red and blue are two colors that
are mostly used in oppositional
engagements when anyone talks about
teams it's always red team versus blue
team
never something like yellow vs purple
and this is no different it even shows
in their swords the amato takes the
devil and human of virgil and splits it
in half the rebellion however takes the
devil and human of dante and combines
them
i really liked that small detail with
the two of them really enforcing that
rivalry they've had for years as they
truly are the opposite of each other
one who rejects his devil heritage and
the other who embraces it
right when we're about to defeat virgil
though someone intervenes
that someone is nero who happens to have
activated his
devil form i said earlier that mission
13 started the high point of the game
for me but this bar was raised even
higher at this point i was genuinely
enthralled by what was going on
in front of me to explain what exactly
just happened the game continues from
the previous cutscene where we discover
that nero is virgil's son
nero from the start of the game has been
upsetted himself since he never had the
strength to deal with his issues
he couldn't defeat yurizin he got his
arm stolen by virgil amongst a host of
other issues that probably occurred in
dmc 4. but he vows that this time is
different and that he's going to stop
these two from killing each other these
emotions and feelings he was having
while charging up the stairs caused him
to get his arm back and activate his
devil mode
both of the brothers are completely
shocked at this discovery and both of
them agree that nero's not going to stop
them from
fighting though nero only has to deal
with virgil however as he almost
practically killed dante with that swing
earlier the fight against virgil as nero
is super one-sided nero's devil trigger
is completely busted doing a disgusting
amount of damage to virgil
the fight was also accompanied by the
song silver bullet so there's
absolutely nothing bad about this fight
it had fan service
good combat excellent soundtrack and a
wonderful set piece for the final fight
an absolute a plus or if we're going by
the game's rules it's a triple s
after the fight is over it goes into a
long stretch of cutscenes
dante and virgil vowed to destroy the
clifoth together leaving nero to deal
with anything that happens in the human
world
i don't know if this means dante and
virgil are staying in the demon realm
forever or they're
going there briefly but judging how they
time skip a month from now and they're
still there i'm assuming they're going
to be there for a bit longer than they
should be if you thought the fan service
of these two fighting before was great
then you'll be in awe of how wonderful
this is
i've watched all of naruto of course i'm
going to enjoy two rivals fighting even
if it's after a dozen fights because
they make the fights look good
every single time and seeing these two
go from fighting each other to teaming
up
then back to fighting was exceptional
if this video is any indication devil
may cry has become one of my favorite
games this year
it's a game i never expected to like but
not only liked but was blown away by its
presentation
combat storytelling and cinematography
it's a game i'll be playing again very
soon as i'm just as eager to hop back in
as i was to play it for the first time
it's always nice to get out of your
comfort zone with certain genres and i
hopefully this encourages you to do the
same
maybe try a racing game delve into
roguelikes or maybe some other genre or
maybe
you're content with the genres you have
and i think that's totally acceptable
too but this video not only serves as a
recommendation for devil may cry 5 but
also a reminder that trying out that new
game you've been thinking about
probably won't go as bad as you think it
will but like i've said i've run out of
time for today so it's probably good to
segue into those calls to action youtube
wants me to do so like the video if you
do enjoy it
also subscribe if you're new for more
videos like this one and if you're a
returning viewer i thank you for coming
back
with that take care everyone and goodbye
[Music]
you